خلال العام الماضي ، عززت العلاقات الثنائية
بين المملكة العربية السعودية واليونان
على عدة جبهات ما هو
المجال الرئيسي للتعاون بين
البلدين هناك رئيس
وزرائنا كان هنا مؤخرًا في
أكتوبر 21 أكتوبر وشارك في
مبادرة الشرق الأوسط الخضراء وأيضًا
مبادرة الاستثمار المستقبلي التي التقى بها
صاحب السمو الملكي ولي العهد
وتوسعا معًا في جميع
الجوانب المهمة لعلاقاتنا الثنائية
، واستثمارات التجارة الأمنية والدفاعية
، والسياحة الثقافية وجميع
الجوانب الأخرى التي يجب أن
نعمل عليها بشكل أكبر من أجل تعزيز جهودنا.
تعتبر العلاقات الثنائية الثنائية
اليونان مركزًا ثقافيًا رئيسيًا ، أعني
أنها تُعرف باسم مهد
الحضارة الغربية وتخطط المملكة العربية السعودية
لعرض الثقافة العربية
قبل رؤية 2030. فهل هناك
مساحة للتعاون
الثقافي وتبادل الخبرات
بين البلدين
هناك مساحة واسعة للتعاون الثقافي
بين بلدينا
اليونان معروفة على نطاق واسع بأنها مهد
الحضارة الأوروبية
ولكن المملكة العربية السعودية هي أيضًا مركز
العالم الإسلامي وكان العالم العربي
حضارتين قديمتين كان لهما
تأثير مهم
، وفي هذا لدينا الكثير من القواسم
المشتركة  بالطبع في الثقافة ، هناك الكثير الذي
يمكننا تعلمه من بعضنا البعض ولكن هناك
الكثير أيضًا من الخبرة عندما يكون لدى مشاركة
اليونان معرفة ودراية مهمة
في الحفريات الأثرية
في الحفاظ على القطع الأثرية
في
ترميم الآثار القديمة وكل
هذه المعرفة موجودة في ذلك  يمكن استخدامه من
قبل المملكة العربية السعودية ، وهو متاح
للمملكة العربية السعودية ، وأعتقد أن هناك
بالفعل مشروع مستمر
لتطوير تطوير الخبرة اليونانية في
التنقيب عن المواقع الأثرية
وهو يتعلق بكوريا حتى
منطقة قرطاجنة بالضبط أنت '  إعادة
قراءة رأيي ، نعم
لقد اكتشفوا التماثيل اليونانية القديمة
ولكن تم إنتاجها محليًا ،
لذلك هناك ما
هو لدينا  كما كان معروفًا ،
أعني أن حضارتنا كانت تعرف
بعضها البعض منذ العصور القديمة ، فقد
تناولت الزيارة الأخيرة التي قام بها وزير خارجية المملكة العربية السعودية إلى أثينا للقاء نظيره اليوناني التعاون أيضًا
على جبهات مختلفة كما ذكرنا
الاستثمار السياحي ولكن أيضًا على
طاولة المناقشة  كان الحوار السياسي
بين البلدين
حيث تقف الدول على هذه
الجوانب السياسية المختلفة
لدينا أهداف مشتركة لدينا هدفنا هو
الحفاظ على السلام والاستقرار في كل من منطقتنا
في شرق البحر الأبيض المتوسط والخليج ول
ذا السبب قمنا بتنظيم  في أثينا أه
في شهر فبراير 21
منتدى فيليا الذي يعني صداقة
بمشاركة المملكة العربية
السعودية والإمارات والبحرين
وفرنسا
ومصر وهذه الدول
أصدرت بيانا مشتركا حول
مدى أهمية التمكن من دعم
القانون الدولي  قانون البحار
وعلاقات حسن الجوار في منطقتنا ونعلم
أننا أنفسنا نريد أن يكون لدينا جدا
الجار المهم وهو
تركيا والذي نحاول معه إقامة علاقات حسن
الجوار ، كانت هناك
توترات مهمة في الماضي ،
ولا نريد تكرار هذه التوترات
ومن المهم أن نكون قادرين على المناقشة
معهم بصراحة وصراحة.
قطاع الدفاع
عندما يتعلق الأمر بتعزيز العلاقات الثنائية ،
يعتبر الدفاع موضوعًا رئيسيًا
للنقاش حول
كيف يمكن لنشر نظام
باتريوت اليوناني المضاد للصواريخ في المملكة
العربية السعودية أن يساعد في تعزيز التعاون العسكري
بين البلدين ،
ونحن نتفهم أهمية الأمن القومي ،
وهذا أيضًا هو  نفس الحالة بالنسبة
للمملكة العربية السعودية حيث
يتم تحدي أمنها القومي كل يوم
بالصواريخ لذلك أعتقد أن هناك
تفاهمًا مشتركًا حول
أهمية الحفاظ على
الأمن القومي لدولة واحدة ، اليونان والمملكة
العربية السعودية
تقومان بتمارين عسكرية مشتركة أه  أحدثها
فالكون i1 و falcon i2 كانوا ناجحين للغاية
وهناك
و gree  يتفهم الرئيس التنفيذي
للتهديدات ولهذا السبب يساهم
بشكل كبير
بإرسال صواريخ باتريوت
الدفاعية والتي ستساهم في الدفاع
عن
الأمن القومي السعودي.
حول المملكة في عام 2019.
كيف تنظر اليونان إلى هذه الاعتداءات المستمرة
، كان الرد دعوة بعد
الحدثين في قرينة وأيام
سبتمبر 2019.
حل
الصراع اليمني
ونعتقد أن العملية السياسية
هي السبيل الوحيد لحل
هذه المشكلة.رؤية 2030 تحولية
للمملكة العربية السعودية
هل
تخطط اليونان للمشاركة في هذا المشروع من
أجل المنفعة المتبادلة لليونان
والمملكة العربية السعودية بالطبع نحن
لدينا بالفعل الكثير من الشركات اليونانية
التي تشارك و professio اليونانية  nals
الذين يشاركون في مشاريع جارية في
المملكة العربية السعودية ولكن هناك الكثير الذي
يمكن القيام به معًا لأنه في جميع
هذه المجالات التي تعتبر في غاية
الأهمية لرؤية 2030 مثل
السياحة والثقافة الترفيهية
أه تحول اقتصادات
اليونان لديها خبرة مهمة
ويمكننا  المساهمة في
كل هذه المجالات الجديدة الناشئة
أه
الاقتصاد الرقمي
أه تكنولوجيا
البنية التحتية المالية
الخدمات المالية هناك معرفة مهمة
في اليونان
وسنكون متحمسين للغاية
للمساهمة بشكل أكبر في
التنمية
والتنفيذ الناجح لرؤية 2013 المملكة العربية السعودية
أعتقد أنه من المهم جدًا بالنسبة لنا أن تكون
هذه الرؤية 2030 ناجحة بقدر ما
يمكن أن
تكون هذه من أجل
مستقبل هذه المنطقة ولكن أيضًا
لمستقبل أه
كل هذه المنطقة التي هي جارة
لليونان وجارة  أوروبا
ستؤثر
عليها ستغير كل شيء أه صمت
المملكة العربية السعودية بشكل حديث وحديث و
طريقة نابضة بالحياة في العالم التنافسي
العالمي وأعتقد أنها
ستجعل جهات اتصالنا أسهل بكثير لأن
موظفينا سيكونون في وضع يسمح لهم
بالاتصال بالسفر بسهولة أكبر
وأيضًا لفهم
[الموسيقى]
بعضهم البعض كتم الصوت فهم
كل منهما  سفير آخر أفضل بكثير لقد
عشت في الرياض لبعض الوقت الآن
ما القليل من الأشياء التي تحبها
في المدينة وهذا البلد
بشكل عام هل هناك أشياء
تذكرك بمن نعم أه هناك العديد من الأشياء
التي تجعلني أفعل  أشعر براحة شديدة
هنا في المملكة العربية السعودية ،
لقد كنت
أعيش هنا منذ بضع سنوات ،
ومن المدهش أن عدد
الأشياء المشتركة التي نشاركها في
تاريخنا مهم بالنسبة لنا ، إن
هويتنا الوطنية متجذرة في
هويتنا  وهذا واضح جدًا في
أننا فخورون جدًا بتاريخنا ، فنحن
فخورون جدًا بما حدث في
الماضي ويسعدنا أن
نشاركه ، ولكن هناك أيضًا سمات مشتركة
في عقلية الطريقة  نعتقد
أن فال  نحن لدينا
عائلة مهم جدًا بالنسبة لنا
نحن أم
نحن قريبون جدًا من عائلتنا
لأنهم لديهم هذه
الروابط المتماسكة للغاية مع أفراد
عائلتنا الذين يدعمون أطفالهم
طوال فترة تعليمهم الديني
أيضًا
ميزة مشتركة مهمة جدًا لدينا ،
إنها جزء من تقاليدنا ، إنها جزء
من هويتنا في نفس الوقت كوننا
متسامحين ومنفتحين على الديانات الأخرى ولكن
هناك الكثير من القواسم المشتركة ، من
المدهش
كم لدينا
كم عدد الأشياء التي لدينا  شارك شكراً
جزيلاً على وقتك السيد السفير ، كان
من دواعي سروري التحدث إليكم.
كان من دواعي سروري أن أشكركم جزيل الشكر ، أنا
ممتن جدًا لك وممتنًا جدًا
لله.